what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and it looks like there's some
pretty interesting stuff about to go
down
in the loki series and of course in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness
kevin feige the president of marvel
studios has recently come out and said
something very
interesting about the loki series that
is getting fans pretty excited because
this means that we could be seeing some
old characters
or different versions of some characters
in the mcu
which of course i think is something
that people could have expected from
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness but
it looks like they could be coming in
loki specifically we could be
seen tony stark in the loki series but
here's the kicker is it actually going
to be
robert downey jr's tony stark or is it
going to be somebody new
don't worry i'll break down everything
you need to know in this video but
reminder only 10 days left in my
stormbreaker giveaway to enter just
subscribe to my channel and to cosmic
culture
link in the description down below so
let's start off by talking about
what kevin feige has recently said about
the loki series
during an interview with entertainment
weekly this is what he had to say about
the show
part of the fun of the multiverse and
playing with time
is seeing other versions of characters
and other versions of the titular
character
in particular now as i mentioned this is
something that we expected to see
in doctor strange but not loki but when
entertainment weekly
asked him if loki would tie into doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
kevin feige declined to confirm so he
wouldn't say yes or no
but let's face it this is the marvel
cinematic universe everything is pretty
much all connected
so in the loki series we're going to be
seeing different versions of
other characters that we've already seen
before and this makes sense because in
the trailers that we've seen for loki
the tva has showed us that loki has
really messed up their timeline which
they refer to as
the sacred timeline and interestingly
enough in this entertainment weekly
article they stated that there will be
a lot more time travel in loki
in comparison to end game so a lot more
time travel this
opens it up to see a lot more different
characters and the cool thing is
is that we've already seen in the loki
series some of these alternate timelines
are not anywhere
near what happens in the main timeline
in one of the timelines that they visit
it looks like new york
is completely destroyed we see a broken
and destroyed avengers tower in the
background
and it looks like female loki could
actually be the cause of this so that's
already one different version of loki
and then of course we know that there's
going to be a kid loki as well
but what about other characters we could
see different versions of thor
odin friega pretty much anybody from the
thor movies but what about some of the
other avengers
we can see different versions of
characters like tony stark
black widow the hulk perhaps captain
america
these characters that are gone from the
mcu right now could return
only slightly different and this
actually lines up with a recent report
from giant freakingrobot.com
they recently stated that they weren't
able to confirm what the exact project
would be but they are certain that
marvel studios is trying to find a young
actor to play a young and future
iron man i'm not so sure about getting
an iron man for
the future to me there's really only one
tony stark however
with the recent comments of kevin feige
it would make sense that we could see
a young tony stark in the loki series
and there are many different
alternate versions of characters that we
could see some of which could still be
played by robert downey jr because
they don't have to be a young tony stark
it could just be a different tony stark
and as far as multiverse of madness is
concerned
this is pretty much what we're going to
be getting alternate versions of
characters coming from different
realities and dimensions
however at this point it does seem like
there are many different things that are
causing the multiverse to go into
madness
the snap could be one of them wanda
could be one of them and now it looks
like loki is going to have some type of
contribution to this as well
so although kevin feige has declined on
whether or not loki is going to connect
to multiverse of madness or not i'm
going to go ahead and say
yes whether indirect or directly i'm
sure loki and
everything that's happening with the tva
is going to cause some type of trouble
for doctor strange in the next film
which is actually pretty exciting
because that means we can see a lot of
alternate versions of the characters
that we know and love
in the upcoming films and hopefully tony
stark could be one of them so be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out any videos if i
hear anything else about these alternate
versions of characters i'll be sure to
do a video and let everybody know
in the meantime let me know which
characters you would like to see show up
in loki and multiverse madness in the
comments down below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof
you